[Music]
hey what is going on YouTube
yes different angles different look this
target t-shirt I bought for an audition
for a role that I didn't get now if you
guys have been noticing that you've been
on my channel I've just kind of been
doing random things and specifically
I've been answering a lot of questions
that you've been asking that I haven't
had the time to do before well I'm
taking the time to answer your questions
and one of the biggest questions that
I've been getting is what type of
equipment should I buy if I wanted to
get into filmmaking and/or being a
serious youtuber now that question in
and of itself is a very difficult
question to answer because it really
depends on how much money you have the
budget and what you want to do but today
I'm going to give you a quick setup of a
camera and two lenses that you need to
shoot just about anything that you want
in terms of short film vlogging whatever
you want on this platform there's a
camera that I just bought today
now with this camera I have been waiting
for it for maybe about two years because
the first generation was amazing in and
of itself it was revolutionary a lot of
people bought it and a lot of people
still use it today but they fixed a lot
of the [ __ ] that I hated on it before
and I'm talking about mother [ __ ] the
Panasonic gh4 yeah I've been waiting for
this point yeah this bad boy is what I
call the future of filmmaking now I'm
not going to go into tech specifics
about this camera because most of you
[ __ ] out there could really
give a [ __ ] less and I understand it
because I don't give a [ __ ] either but
let me just give you a reason why this
camera is absolutely amazing now this
camera right here is going to roughly
run you about 1900 to 2000 dollars yes
it's pricey but relative to what it can
do and how long this is going to last
for you on this platform is worth every
[ __ ] penny now let's talk about the
physical aspects of this camera number
one this camera feels amazing it's good
in the hands the grip is really
comfortable and when you start to shoot
a lot you will start to realize how
important it is to have a comfortable
camera it fits well in your hands if you
will be able to jazz up it you will be
able to shoot for a long time without
complaining
outrightly conversely i also shoot with
two Sony mirrorless cameras and those
bodies are smaller and it's great
because contact but it's not great for
shooting percent because it's very
uncomfortable in my hand my hands are a
little bit larger and so it's kind of
hard for me to jostle around and it
makes my hand cramp up a lot the second
amazing thing about this camera aside
from the fact that the body feels great
it has a fully tilting extendable
variable screen this right here is going
to be your light saver nice save I sense
a river break why you ask because for
those of you out there that want to get
into the blogging game where you want to
film your beautiful [ __ ] face and
guess what what better way than having a
variable screen also if you're filming
yourself in multiple different
characters will guess what if you need a
fine focus or you need to see that the
frame is right you have the screen out
for you so you could check it yourself
and you don't need somebody else to tell
you that you're in focus also that I
mentioned this camera has great
autofocus capabilities which means that
when you're shooting yourself you don't
have to worry about the focus going on
out of black because the video autofocus
will do that for you another thing that
this cameras does which a lot of cameras
do now too is that it shoots forth tape
it's not necessary but it helps when
you're shooting something that sometimes
you want to snap zoom or you want to
focus on different things or you don't
want to grab a different shot to get it
close because it's just going to be a
simple schedule text but if you have
been 4k and your downscaling your
resolution out to 1080p anyways well if
you blow up the picture it'll still be a
great resolution that image will still
be sharp because it's a 4k [ __ ]
footage and if you upscale it a little
bit
it'll be fine a saves you a lot of time
or you filmmakers out there that do want
to go into coloring this does have a
flat picture profiles called v-log I
believe and it shoots for two to ten bit
internally yet you don't need an
external recorder to get that or two to
ten bits done for those people out there
who don't know what it is I'm not going
to sit here explain to you because it's
a waste time and most likely once again
they don't give a good this camera also
has image stabilization have you seen
those old YouTube clips when you were
shooting it and this camera was super
shaky and it was weird and just very
jarring well guess what when you have
stabilization is going to help out a lot
with that which dystonias have as well
Panasonic as well awesome thank you very
much I love the fact this has a lot of
hardware buttons hardware buttons are
very important to me because when I'm
shooting I want to access my things as
soon as possible this has no problem
with that whatsoever
a lot of customizable buttons super easy
to access your ISO your white balance
your aperture everything else next up
let's talk about lenses now one of the
things that people tend to [ __ ] up on
when they start shooting is that they
think that they need a lot of lenses you
really don't need that many and even if
you're not shooting schedule some of my
favorite DPS and videographers that
shoot like travel videos that I follow
they really only use about two or three
lenses and the two lenses that I bought
for this camera and the ones that I use
when I travel are going to be a wide
zoom and one prime lens the wide zoom
that I got from my Panasonic is going to
be the Panasonic Lumix G Vario 7 to 14
now this camera is a micro 4/3 sensors
so basically what that means is that
whatever you see to be the focal length
on this lens is going to be x 2 so this
camera is actually a 14 to 28 now
wide-angle closes are going to be a
preference for you if you don't like it
that's all up to you it's just what I
like for my taste so bada-bing bada-boom
da da da not even words the second ones
that I got for my pentatonic is the 25ml
but after conversion roughly about a 50
mil 1/4 the reason why I love this lens
so much and is the preferred prime that
I'd like to use is because the focal
length is decent a 50 mil is always
something that you should have on hand
and on top of that if super light is
compact it's not going to get in the way
and if you're doing travel videography
you want to pack light so this is what
it is people this is my general camera
setup I don't have a lot of things well
that's not sure I do have a lot of
equipment like I said a 7 is 2 a7 r2 I
even have an F that's 5 but here's the
thing I have 20 lenses I only use about
2 so if you're thinking out there right
now that you need to buy like a stupid
amount of lenses to get great shots you
don't and I want to derive this and for
you
right now just so we don't waste money
in the future it's not really so much
about the equipment to a certain extent
I'm going to use as an example just to
drive this point you guys remember that
called buying well all that stuff was
shot on an iPhone camera basically it
going to require amazing or expensive
equipment and it did it require multiple
lenses
it required thought writing and
understanding like community timing and
beads this is just a tool that will
enhance already the content that you can
put out now if you don't have like
roughly about 3500 bucks to afford these
two letters and this camera and a couple
of batteries
well you're not it's not the end of the
world there are other options that don't
shoot 4k or even does shoot 4k that's
cheaper that is very comparable to this
but this is my personal set up that I
like that I will be keeping for a very
long time that I will be shooting a
majority of my things on for maybe the
next four or five years don't ever let
your equipment be a reason why you are
not creating content that [ __ ] is just
[ __ ] and excuses like I said the
people that I follow that I look up to
use about two or three lenses when they
do these quick shoots and their stuff
looks absolutely amazing and that's
because of their thought process and the
things that they create they don't let
equipment and money get in their way and
neither should you when I first started
doing YouTube I shot on this little
Panasonic like zoom toggle like HD thing
that my dad had I mean it was anything
that I could get my hands on people
watch the stuff because the content was
good not the camera but once again if
you are looking to buy something that
will last for a while take my advice to
try this out great good upward angle
extra double chin extra titties
what me nobody wants to do me maybe
write about Little Billy Crimson you
wanna see something cool I kind of hold
snacks in my lap they would have gone on
YouTube I hope you like that unboxing
video if you want to see me unbox [ __ ]
like cool new equipment tech I could do
it in the day too so late because most
people when they do these unboxing
videos they're not [ __ ] entertaining
for [ __ ] that I can even unlock the
weirdest things for you and try them out
and use them on this video leave it in
the comments below let me know what you
want me to
let me know if you want to do another
buff bomb I can do articles with you
guys like I'm here for you I'm just
having followed by YouTube I've been on
this channel for like five years now
insider has what I connect with you who
call me